Knapsack is a very interesting problem because in a way and this is very informal, of course,
it is among the easiest NP complete problems.
So, where as clique and independent set for example seem to be very difficult,
Knapsack allows for some pretty interesting algorithms and both of those
algorithms which will be important for our P-test is called pseudopolynomial algorithm
and you'll soon see why it is named that way.
I'm first going to explain the algorithm to you; so you're given an instance of knapsack,
which means you're given n objects.
Each one has size s so we'll just label those sizes here S₁, S₂ until you get to Sn.
Each object also has a value so the values will be labeled in the same way.
So you have V₁, V₂ and so on until you get to V-sub-n.
And now, here's the algorithm to solve knapsack.
The algorithm basically works for the table that looks like this.
The table has n rows one, two, three down to n
and the table has a lot of columns one, two, three, four, five, and so on and so on and so on
until we get to a number that I'll call V.
And by V, I mean the sum of these values here.
So the total V₁ plus V₂ and so on plus V-sub-n will be called B.
And this is the table that we'll now use. Of course, I still have to tell you what values go into that table.
Each cell here in this table is going to have the following meaning.
I'll call the row that we're at I and I'll call the column that we're at J.
Then, this cell here in row I and column J has the following meaning
The cell here in this table will be the minimum size required to achieve a total value of exactly J
Using the objects one, two, three, four, and so on until you get to I, so you cannot use all objects
So, for example, in the first you row, you can only use object one
In the second row, you can only use objects one and two
and in the third row, objects one, two, and three and so on
and that means that sometimes, of course, it's not possible
to achieve a value of exactly J using these objects
and so, we'll just write a dash into the table if that's not possible.
So, let's use the example from before so you have the objects A, B, C, D, E, F, G
and here we have the sizes and the values.
So, the sizes were three, two, two, three, and so on.
And to construct this table here, we'll, of course, have to label those items here
So, this is item one, this is item two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So, my first question to you now, a brief quiz here.
What do we put in here?
So, how many columns does this table have and how many rows does this table have?